yeah so
bitcoin is it's digital energy right
this is a big idea we've encrypted
money
right it's such a huge idea since most
people don't know what money is it
doesn't occur then that money is energy
since they don't understand what money
is they don't really understand that
money's defective
that the energy is bleeding out of their
currency and by the way
if
if money is energy the energy finds its
way into a currency it also finds its
way into into stocks and into bonds and
into
property they're all bleeding energy
over time or over space
and if you're an engineer
and you understand that a
well-engineered system is a system that
allows you to move energy through time
and space with no power loss no
impedance superconducting
which is
that we call that like uh you know it's
an adiabatic system or a
thermodynamically sound system
if you're an engineer you totally get it
when you're designing a pneumatic system
electrical system you know even a
heating system in a house or a swimming
pool
if the if the water drained out of your
swimming pool wouldn't work so well
right if your bathtub you know drained
out it was doesn't work so well
so
engineers understand this but economists
don't really think of money as energy
and so they it doesn't occur to them
that the energy is bleeding out of
the systems
once you figure that out you realize
that bitcoin is truly brilliant because
what they've done
is they've created a
thermodynamically sound monetary network
that allows you to store any amount of
energy
for any period of time
and move it at essentially no cost
anywhere in space as frequently as you
want so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]